The graph that we selected in the last video is unlike any other function we've
seen before. And in fact, it's a different kind of exponential function. This
graph shows another function that follows the same sort of pattern. Now, since
I've told you that the graph is exponential, we have an idea of what kind of
behavior it exhibits. Every time we add some constant amount to x, f is going
to increase by a certain percent, or is going to be multiplied by a certain
number. So, for example, if we add 1 to x here, what is f of x multiplied by?
I'll label a few points on this graph to make things a bit simpler. Now think
carefully about this. Make sure that you fill in the number f of x is
multiplied by.